we now have the absolute final
numbers for not only donald trump but
melania trump we are turning the page we
are starting a new era it is the joe
biden era
and what is an unfortunate irreversible
reality now that trump is done
is that donald trump has exited as the
least popular
president in history for as long as
there has been polling
and melania trump not to be outdone
is the least popular first lady in the
history
of the u.s for as long as there has been
polling
uh i gave you the numbers yesterday
according to pew research
trump's uh approval bottomed out at 29
percent yesterday
uh on gallup trump bottomed out at 34
but we now have the presidency wide
numbers trump's average approval
throughout his presidency
is 41 that is the least
popular president in the history
of the polling era trump also the only
president
never to at any time in the gallup
tracking survey
have 50 approval so trump
never hit 50 percent averaged 41
a low of any president in history and
going out at 34
the lowest of his entire presidency now
um
strictly speaking it's an appeal to
authority to say that a president's
popularity tells us if they were a good
or a bad president that's not what i'm
doing
i'm not saying trump was good or bad on
the basis of his approval
i am merely telling you that the guy
obsessed with good marks and popularity
and feeding his ego and being well liked
is the least well-liked president
in the history of the united states
during the polling era
similarly melania trump leaving the
white house
with the worst popularity rating
for any first lady at the end of her
term
in polling history cnn ssrs
has trump at 42 to 47.
um first ladies are just popular you
might say well 42 is not that bad
first ladies often have 60 or even 70
uh popularity um
it's it's really something else and to
be to be perfectly frank
melania was barely a first lady she
didn't do and didn't appear um
at many of the things and in many of the
places that first ladies traditionally
have appeared at
she was a complete and total non-factor
it seems pretty clear she wanted nothing
to do with this presidency and it seems
pretty clear
at least from time to time it wasn't
clear she wanted much to do with donald
trump so we're really closing the book
on this
in a way that it's really not sad for me
the sad part is that their approval is
even as high as it is as i've said
before
their approval ratings should be
dramatically lower
but as uh as donald trump famously said
it is what it is
and trump will go into history as the
least popular president
in the history of the united states one
of our sponsors today is magic spoon the
reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video